when Lori got into trouble with her
daughter and the whole College Scandal
and all that mhm and you're so close
with her you worked with her for years
yeah how did you handle that they wanted
me to write about the book and I asked
her and she said yeah write anything you
want so I wrote about the morning that I
heard about it so she was in Canada and
my friend Roger Lodge texted me said is
Lori okay it was early to and I said
what do you mean some college Scandal
thing so I'm looking on Googling it I
didn't I saw one little thing and it was
early I called her up I said hey how you
doing uh you okay and she's like yeah
why I said well I just hearing something
this college Scandal what was that about
and she said oh I don't know she said
but M Mo handles on the dad um you know
I saw a couple emails from a lawyer but
I don't think it's any big deal I said
okay and then I heard a click on the
phone I said did you hear that another
click she goes yeah I think they're
bugging my phone I said what goodby
wrong number hang up on her and um and
then so I turn on the news and it became
you know the the FBI were on there this
is the biggest college scandal in
history and I I text her I go are you
you watching the news and she's like no
I go what do you mean no I said there's
there's a press conf she what's it about
I said you she she said I still have the
text she goes what channel I go all caps
every channel and then that was it I
didn't hear from her for a bit because
they at that point they I think they
rushed in and got masimo here in in
California and then she you know then
they got into it it was you know the
last person on Full House you'd think
would go to jail as her was the Press
asking you for quotes or like some
comment and what do you do you just kind
of hide yeah I didn't say anything you
know for the cuz you couldn't win you
know and you wanted to defend your but
she you know what look what I so then I
the angle on the book was this I said um
I talked about the morning I said I said
people make mistakes some big some small
but it's how you deal with the
accountability afterwards it's how you
deal with it and the way she dealt with
it was better than I could have done for
sure she stood up and she fiercely
defended her family and it was it was
very difficult obviously people were
slinging at their kids you know
that would be terrible right and and you
know she wanted it was bad and I was she
was a study in uh uh um you know
tenacity I mean she just didn't let it
she nearly was broken completely but she
held on to it and kept her family
together and I loved her for that and
what did you say about Lor llin in the
book that they there was some romantic
feelings there right like you little bit
is it hard for you to be friends like
does her husband get jealous like I I
wouldn't want you contacting my wife
constantly there was a thing where I
said a few years ago like she was the
one that got away or whatever like I
should have been with her and it went
everywhere and I said to her I said Mas
does he hate does he no she he didn't
give a so I don't know we we're
friends they they literally live you
know a block away from me now is she the
one that got away seriously do you think
you could have had a great life with her
I have a great life with
Caitlyn